I don't really know what a California
girl consists so I would define a
California girl as me Sporty's me a
little bit more carefree no Tom just a
lot of fun
hey get any more California to me hello
why I live in Kelly if you don't play
sports blond hair blond hair blue eyes
likes to have fun tan skin you might as
well win a [ __ ] Idaho keeping don't
work out at it kid
volleyball tennis that's being a
California girl looking good doing it
and I'm saying and and I think my trying
to say that that's a California girl
do we even have style it's a little bit
casual James and sweats very girly
whatever it's playing in my closet I
love flat I like to wear things that fit
me I like to keep myself for an event
that we're going to one day I could be a
tomboy one day I could be wearing a
dress and get a girl
now that you're lying to my face and you
talk I'm pissed and have a dark side too
I dress really sporty polka dots really
whatever my mood is that's what I wear I
work part of my body on the show it you
know
huh anything by Huntress Thompson on my
favorites is Family Fare 1984 Wow this
way that's like brown hair huh my shoes
shoes I feel like we have a lot of shoe
shoes what shoes not just she's it's
like shoes
hi shoes we need a private best this
year when she's warm to my yep I can
walk out naked and just use I often do a
probably coat that goes with everything
and then purses in yeah
yeah